good morning everybody happy Wednesday
it's great to be with you guys again
today I'm still sick but it doesn't mean
we can't be grateful welcome to
gratitude journal live stream number 43
and we do this every day we try to be
consistent with our gratitude so it's
not once a week or once a month every
day and think about why we're grateful
for the things that we list try to feel
it if you do that you get the emotional
benefits and with a little bit of time
that daily practice will lead to some
pretty incredible results in your life
in your business bear with my throat
than sniffles today i'm even started off
we're going to then head to the live
chat and then you guys watching
afterwards leave three things or give
before down the comment below for me
number one i'm good for naps yesterday i
was i was also sick and working crazy
hard uh and then crashed and ended up
having a nap I don't nap that often just
in general uh but I had a had a nice nap
yesterday that rejuvenated me and
allowed me to stay up probably later
than I should have watching the election
last night in the u.s. to see what the
results would be so grateful for the
ability to take naps when needed uh the
second time grateful for is is taking
responsibility I'm grateful that that I
take responsibility for what's going on
and there's something negative happens
that I don't agree with I look at how
could I of that better not just blaming
something else I woke up this morning to
a bunch of comments from the election
and half of them are half the people are
amazingly happy and this is a new era
and half the people are just totally
de-stressed and depressed and when I
think about it think about a recent
event that happened with uh with Hayden
of this school hidden my son is seven
years old is there
it was there was a bully at school who
made him throw a rock at another kid and
now we got called in and said neons is
not you know the school let us know what
happened and I had to have a talk with
him and one to let him know that
obviously shouldn't be hanging around
that bully and he gets to make up his
own mind he doesn't do it have to do
anything that somebody else tells him to
do but I took it an extra step and say
you know what if you're seeing bullying
around your school with your classmates
or with people who are younger than you
because this bullies at every level that
it's up to you to also step in and and
be a force for good weather that's
breaking up a fight that's happening or
even if it's just being being there for
the person who's being bullied so that
they don't feel alone afterwards know if
you see somebody cried after they were
bullied you know it's up to you to go
over and ask if they're okay and be
their friend it's to take your
responsibility not just for your own
life but for others as well I think it's
it's important it's what I believe in is
what I want to pass on to my next
generation hopefully you guys too and so
when I look at an election result or I
look at something that happens in the
world you know if I'm not if I'm not
happy with it for those of you who you
know who won last night great
congratulations for the view who didn't
who feel depressed instead of there's a
lot of blame going around and instead of
blaming I'd look inward and think hey
did I do enough like did I go ahead and
vote and voting is just a bare minimum
did I go and mobilize that I get people
involved you know how could I have done
better so that this day could have been
different and if you look at what you
did if you look at the actions that you
took compared to the amount of
complaining that you're doing there's
probably a big disconnect and that's
just in general is for a lot of things
like I don't have a stake in the
election I don't really care I'm you
know I'm Canadian I've said from the
beginning that doesn't matter to me who
wins I'm still going to go out and get
mine the idea that the president
is going to be the difference-maker in
my business being successful or not is
crazy so you don't bank on that right
there's nobody who's coming to save your
business it's up to you to do it but if
there's something going on that you
don't agree with instead of complaining
take responsibility take action ask how
you could have done better and then make
sure that doesn't happen the next time
that you put your absolute best into it
less complaining more action I think
it's important it's my rant of the day
come on a rant of the day ah number
three when I'm grateful for I'm good for
this video day it's Wednesday for me I
film all my videos for the YouTube
channel it's going to be a going to be a
fun challenge today to get through it
but I never missed looking for what I've
been insanely sick I've never missed uh
I'll find a way to do it because I love
making this stuff and I love helping you
guys and so I'm a funnel your energy
through my video camera to make it
happen today so that's what I got people
for naps good for taking responsibility
grateful for it being video day let's
get to the live stream the live chats
who you guys have going on miha
villainous ave believe nation whether
you give it for today i'm good for
innovations and technology just help me
improve my knowledge and make my
projects more functional and successful
I like that I like that welcome back my
hovel by the way it's great to see you
back here Mitchell today I'm grateful
for water water super important I have
water and tea and various water
concoctions around me here to try to
help me feel better today to the
challenge is coming up with my one word
super important one of the most at least
in my humble opinion one of the most
valuable exercises you'll ever do in
your life and three the internet I feel
you there Mitchell this would not be
happening without the internet yeah i
mean i remember being in high school and
having to use encyclopedias and books
from my research projects for school
that's crazy how much Internet has
changed things how much how much what i
would add on in high school if i had
internet always around me that would
have been I would have been amazing like
if this existed man I'm so grateful that
it's here now what do we got J reyez
thank thankful for friends who I can
trust and rely on nice for banks /
paypal / money that allow the easy
exchange of value nice for authors who
offer many life lessons stories and info
on all topics under the Sun I love that
uh-oh it skipped say no hey yo i'm
grateful for one living in the
Netherlands where we might not have the
greatest political leader but at least
he's quite harmless I'm super good for
live in Canada I don't know what Justin
Trudeau has done for us again I don't
really follow politics that much but
people love him so it will be Canadian
to getting my backpack with my laptop
and external hard drives in it back
after forgetting it at the snooker club
I feel your pain and congratulations get
in the back I'm ever leaving my laptop
at a club where I was DJing and it's
like panicking I need my laptop in my
laptop and we're closed anyway I'm glad
you got it all back and three headphones
for allowing me to hear things more
clearly helps with editing for example
very cool what else KL bien today I'm
grateful for a quiet morning we're all I
hear are the leaves waving in the wind
very cool to the law of attraction
everything I've been magnetizing to
myself cool worked on a bob Proctor top
ten rules right now that's pretty
interesting so I think you like that
when it comes out and three my youngest
brother for being goofy I love it
Melissa I'm grateful for my hands
because they allow me to grab everything
I want you should talk with much
Jennifer price you had a whole series of
her YouTube channel about her hands and
all the magical things she could do with
them jen is here morning y'all what do
we got what do we got what do we got
jen is capable for the many mentors in
my life I talked to so many people
yesterday who wanted to help me in my
business and I am very very thankful to
each and every one of them I love that
awesome Melissa I'm grateful for new
ideas and projects to do I love that uh
Jay rises saying that wheelie gain no I
have not patched so there's no league
stream there's only cream today and
actually not tomorrow because tour I
have to go do my audio book a couple of
what do they call it pickups pickups I
think so just gratitude stream today and
tomorrow will be back on for Friday but
what do we got anything else grateful
for new opportunities and ideas always
new ways to rise I love that blackjack
good morning I'm thankful for a new day
opportunity for growth and my wife and
children love that what's an
encyclopedia yeah man back in the day
much I'm grateful for my flexibility in
my life and in my muscles very cool nine
ten guys thank you for the fun thank you
for joining me thank you for sharing
your gratitude for the day with me I
always feel energized and extra grateful
reading what you guys are grateful for
so i am i'm gonna get ready for my video
today i hope you guys are getting ready
for whatever it is on your list of
things to do go out and crush it we all
believe in you i hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love guys happy
wednesday i'll see you soon